Sousa dalla itani says do a collab okay
all right five synced up audio is synced
you can do your intro yeah I get to see
you live now there's a net fresh shake
so pumped what is up guys I'm Kim PhD
here and welcome to ask mkbhd or in this
case a bit of a dual asking me episode
it is may I ask you guys what you wanted
to know on Twitter and there are plenty
of questions for both mr. Peter McKinnon
and I we're just gonna go through them
and ask them and hopefully they're good
question my phone is melting right all
right that's a good start yeah plenty to
pick from okay we got who is taller okay
so uh probably tell by this frame right
here I'm clearly go not quite as tall
you're about an inch taller than me and
yeah in standing height I'm like six
four I'm like six three but like my
torso must be that small so we so we
should have like a frisbee showdown for
sure just like who could even can jump
higher I give myself a slight edge there
yes because I got to my game yeah I
don't I don't do sports at all that's
probably you let's go with okay this one
I really love this one what's the first
app that you open in the morning first
app I open every day on my phone is
flamingo for Twitter what I've never
even heard of that
so our IP this is an Android app that
reached its token limit this is
something I could go on a whole rant
about this yeah this I don't know what's
happening so I did it I did a tear a
deer Twitter video I didn't include this
in that video because it wasn't as big
of a deal but Twitter really restricts
how third-party apps can operate and one
of those things is there's a limit to
how many users that they can fill in
before no one can sign up and use the
app anymore it reached that token limit
and now anyone who tries to newly
download it from the Google Play Store
can't sign into Twitter on that ass so
it's one of my favorite apps I use it
every day when I open my phone first
thing in the morning it's probably from
me was actually do
it's just a third party Twitter app it's
purely chronological no ads no like
extra features it's just straight
Twitter because of their appearance form
yeah
because Twitter always is always showing
me like you know like stuff you may have
missed and like this is another
questions chronological is just yeah so
like my first app like Instagram for
sure I open up Instagram all the time
that's applied the photographer the
visual side of what I do and then I just
mad scroll but I just can't stand that
it's not chronological anymore because
I'll over the first thing in the morning
and the first post is from like 13 hours
ago and then the next one's from 13
minutes ago and I think then it's
dinnertime and I'm seeing what I should
have seen in the morning right I'll
never understand alright so this guy's
asking do you are you expecting the
knotch to die by 2020 and your your the
your kind of like the the smartphone
guru or so to you uh
I am hoping yes there's emerging
technologies that will let us put a
fingerprint sensor that will let us put
maybe a front-facing camera all these
different things behind the display
glass hopefully by 2020 that will be the
case and we can eliminate the knotch
yes it's a polarizing thing cuz you
would think like everyone must hate it
but then at the same time
everyone's copying it so it's just weird
yeah I don't like and a lot of people
are like you get used to it it
disappears but it's it has not
disappeared so it disappeared form I
like using the phone everyday type use
but uh I don't want it to be there yeah
and like I don't like when I'm like
watching like even YouTube videos or any
my own work or anything like that I
gotta like Max it out to get rid of or
like shrink it down and I lose left and
right yeah I mean either so yeah i'm
anti notch for sure here's an
interesting one cuz you're you're in
this you're on the camera world but we
got smartphones everywhere yep do you
like the direction phones are headed
with more and more cameras so a single
camera dual camera p20 pro just came out
with three cameras yeah I think that's
incredible okay I mean like yes I use a
DSLR every day of my life but still
being able to have that power
in your back pocket and a moment's
notice without having to set anything up
incredible so I love cameras and
smartphones getting better but I'm not
an
highly convinced that adding more
cameras is always the best thing I'm
actually a fan of what Google is trying
to do of doing better with less not that
you shouldn't add a second camera but I
can get behind doing great portrait mode
and great stuff with one camera like I
never actually use the telephoto I like
I'm very rarely like going to take a
photo and punch in like I never I would
just physically move in closer yeah
so how many people really like need that
second yeah like I would say like if it
was just gone to more like if I woke up
and the second camera had just been
removed from the hardware I probably
wouldn't even notice for like a few
months I think oh where'd my cameras go
here's a fun one though LG came out with
the g7 and they've done this in the
history of their phones with a super
wide angle camera I'm a fan of that yes
that's I think way more useful because
you're in a small space you want to
capture something really really cool
that's happening in front of you but you
can't because you open up your camera
and you're like looking at someone's
eyeball yeah I think the wide-angle LG
does is fundamentally more useful than
the telephoto that may sometimes not
even get used yeah yeah totally agree
with that do you ever feel like
technology is advancing so fast that one
day you won't be able to actually keep
up with it
I got scared of that yeah I get scared
of that like I guess go to two things
when I get old which is I love driving
well I'd become that old guy in the
middle lane that everyone goes what are
you doing yeah well I do you have a life
I'm so scared of that take my license
away but I've become that guy the other
thing is like yeah I'm we're always at
the bleeding edge of like you know new
devices new camera gear and new tech
something's gonna come out some day
where I just go I don't get it yeah like
is that useful is that better maybe I
feel that in life music right now but
like yeah I think about like how old am
I gonna be when I don't understand I
think about that with with editing
actually like there's some times where I
want to achieve something in my
post-production workflow and I'm like
how would I do that and they're like oh
just motion track this to that I'm like
I don't I don't even know what that
means and should I know what that means
and is it weird that all these younger
kids are doing that like effortlessly
and I can't even pronounce the word the
resort to a lot of YouTube tutorials in
that case yeah that's how I learned to
edit in the first place yeah yeah
premiere didn't know how to use it got
it watch a lot of videos on what and
it's I'll never learn everything you can
do in Premiere and after-effects yeah
that's right that's where I learn a lot
you edit on Final Cut though I'm a Final
Cut editor I'm a premier editor yeah I
feel like so I was a premier editor yeah
I know this is a common thing okay so
why premiere you get choice so I used to
use Final Cut 7 I used it for the
longest time Final Cut X had just come
out so like the day it launched
downloaded it hated it got a refund in
like three days never looked back so I
just always assumed it sucked just as
bad yep like today as a did when it
first came out that was a launching
point for a lot of people with Cut Pro
10 it was like the the iMovie Pro like
everyone hated it the magnetic timeline
I was just like what I can't no iris I
never I was on premiere at that point
okay
and it had it's bad rap for a while I
kind of pointed and laughed off so but I
never used it and then a couple updates
later that was actually I've told the
story before the Kobe interview I was
editing in premiere on a MacBook Pro my
buddy John who was editing the behind
the scenes was editing on Final Cut Pro
or the row faster ran it out way faster
I decided to give it a shot and the rest
is history
so I gotten used to Final Cut Pro in
that time all right all right so this is
a fun one I've got I've got it I've got
some thoughts about this do you think
that touch ID will make a comeback
comeback okay so on one hand yes on the
other hand no it's a two-sided answer
again when Apple does something like
this where they just ditch that's a
technology they ditched the fingerprint
reader usually they never go back I miss
it usually they never go back and a lot
of people do miss it but also a lot of
technologies have been developing with
like we talked about that ability to put
a fingerprint sensor under the glass
yeah so if Apple's so set on a bezel
this phone
maybe they adopt this they pick it up
and they do it again for touch ID the
return or whatever I would love to see
that yeah because face ID like I like it
in theory just look at your phone and
you don't have to push anything but more
times than not it's like they almost put
me in more like dangerous situations
like walking into the street and like
I'm driving and I try to just like look
at it can I've always got to put my code
in at the
times and then it's just super
frustrating that was one of those things
I didn't you know the first impressions
I was just kind of getting used to
holding and just unlocking it or
whatever as you use the phone you you
find more and more situations where it's
weirdly uncomfortable like driving your
eyes have to look at the phone to unlock
it so holding it up like this in front
of the road is the most dangerous that
you can do don't do that
there's all kinds of little things
really here it's on your desk and your
editing writers having a great day yeah
lights up yup my litter li did that my
video I feel like it's not as fast did
you pick up my phone thumb was there
boom press swipe like it sits I didn't
even think about it cuz it is just the
button already sites already there
unlocked it maybe Apple will bring that
back let's hope they do right I got one
my most underrated bit of tech in your
tech bag I'm guessing your tech bag is
your camera bag yeah my camera bag yeah
yeah I'll serve this one so it's funny I
always I always put this little die use
this all the time and I put it in a lot
of videos and every time it's in a video
people are always like what is that and
where can I get it which is just kind of
like proof of concept that either just
like flies over everyone's head or it
goes under the radar yeah but it's this
tiny little LED light charges by USB
it's super bright I gaff tape this to
the roof I tape it to like under the
underside of cars that's it it comes
with gels so I can like actually change
the color cast and this thing just comes
off magnets back on you've changed the
light charges by USB it's incredible so
I would say this is probably the most
underrated bit of tech in my bag because
it's one of those things that when you
realize that you need it you're like oh
I have that little it's like it's
perfect
yes yeah so for me I this backpack back
here the only the only stuff I have in
my backpack are my macbook pro the
charger the case it's in and my water
bottle I have an addition to that okay
do you this look at this I have that
this is a must have an adapter dongle
for yeah so SD card reader cuz the
MacBook Pro doesn't have yeah yeah
okay so we got what's your worst camera
just decisions you a lot of cameras yeah
worst worst camera purchase decision
yeah most of my purchases are pretty
well researched and well thought out so
I've seen the reviews I kind of know
what I'm getting into so I do have been
some like impulse like lapse of judgment
sale there's plenty of there's plenty of
like impulse buys that but I usually end
up loving this cuz that's why I got into
them but I'm gonna point back oh it's
way up in the corner the nest cam oh
it's not even a camera purchase it's
that counts but I feel I feel need to
bring it up I tweeted about this little
while ago people will get on my case for
it cuz I should know this already but
Ness doesn't record any of the history
of the camera until you buy an S
subscription for every single camera I
have in that subscription on a different
camera it does not apply to this one
yeah TV over here fell off the wall I
said I need to see this how that
happened
and I went and I got a scroll back and I
have all kinds of complaints about the
app and how it makes it look like you
might as its lagging and I'm like one's
it gonna load I clearly have the hist by
the time it loads the dudes already in
your house exactly your thing so it
looks like we bought the subscription
when we realized we had to for this
camera again and it erased the entire
history of what the camera had ever
recorded that I regret not buying
earlier nest does not record any and
they don't have to it's their business
model 50 bucks for every single
subscription but yeah I regret not not
buying the nest subscription to see how
exactly the wallpaper TV fell off the
wall I don't like that those don't come
with a wall mount that's my beef yeah
there there's little little stands no
wall mount is little magnets okay so
Trent Damon this could be about anything
but he says who do you got in the NBA
playoffs
I'll just saw that I'll translate that
to oh yeah what sports are you into I
know you from Toronto but like yeah I
got the Raptors in the playoffs that's
fair and full disclosure like two weeks
ago I was texting marques and I was
headed to DC for a Raptors game yeah
against the Wizards the Wizards right
yes there's my first I've never seen a
basket I've never seen a basketball game
was my first time ever
good first game to watch it was so great
yeah thoroughly enjoyed it so they still
in it
they're still in it Oh wicket Raptors
for now they're down zero they're down
two out to Cleveland so that's gonna be
a fun oh it's down to now I'm out of
yeah they just lost last night like
worse than before but I got Houston
still I've said this in like two
different q and A's but yeah it's a it's
a pretty pretty exciting time in the
season I like hockey not just because
I'm Canadian I just like how fast-paced
it is okay yeah being at the games it's
just like it happen expecially if you're
right on the glass they're just I like
sports that transition quickly between
offense and defense I play Ultimate
Frisbee it's like that all the time yeah
soccer is like that hockey's like that
basketballs like that fast-paced I can't
like I can't watch golf
I can't watch football I can't watch
football I can't watch baseball
no well football takes like you know
another whole Netflix series to finish
like it's just it just forever so that's
where I'm at with sport yeah all right
here's a good question maybe the last
one is there any tech you wish you could
build I'm gonna I'm gonna twist this one
as he said like a rocket or something
but I'm gonna say like people ask me all
the time if you could build your own
smartphone would you do it and it's
tough because I don't know if I could
control all the pieces and there's a lot
of trade-offs but if you could build
your own like dream camera for your
style yeah would it be something that
already exists or would you like
Frankenstein together some sort of I
feel like I go to a place that would
never be pop like possible like what
yeah like I would love to have some kind
of like Bluetooth connectivity to my
eyes no like I don't think I I don't I
don't think that much about the gear
like it's kind of just a tool for me and
I just like I use it there are little
things
I don't probably I can't recall them
right now but like there's always a
little thing that's like oh but that'd
be better if it was I would love to
shoot with a red camera and everything
it does well and then just grab c200
dual pixel autofocus and put it in there
like that's the type of like I would
love I'd love it this is just the size
of a DSLR yeah that type of thing yeah I
think about that a lot really more than
I should
yeah so taking like the production
quality of a camera like
and crunching it into like a rebel sized
camera ya know there's a lot interesting
stuff going on but I think well we'll
end it on that thank you for being a
part of this Q&A thanks probably collab
many more times I know there's a lot of
camera gear we have more to talk about
but there is a video on your channel
yeah it's either live now or is about to
be and it'll talk more about camera gear
and and get into that stuff so yeah
you're gonna do thanks for watching I
talk to you guys the next one pace